five different ways people handle
conflicts number one the first way
people handle conflicts is the lowest
level this is people who are stubborn
close minded I don't want to hear about
it I don't even want to deal with it I'm
purely stubborn this person I recognize
very well because that's who I was for
the first twenty two years of my life I
knew it all I was stubborn don't tell me
anything I'm good to go
okay stubborn the second level is
somebody that accommodates these are
people that are passive they confirm
okay no problem you guys want to go
there I really don't want to but no
problem or I really don't want to do
that but I get it I don't want to make
you mad no problem
conform conform conform conform conform
second level it's not as bad as stubborn
but it's pretty bad to be conforming all
the time you're always accommodating the
third level is avoiding no I'd rather
not talk to her you know what I can't
even stand what she said the other day
why don't you call her no way I would
never call her I can't believe what he
just said in the other business meaning
how dare he call me out like that in
that business meaning once you get makan
no way I'm not gonna call him up
avoidance avoidance avoidance avoidance
and all of these conflicts in your life
add up you're carrying a 500 pound
backpack if you're constantly avoiding
conflict you are because you're afraid
of avoiding it if you are that level
number four is somebody that compromises
you here a lot of times people say well
I compromise you know I'm willing to
compromise babe why don't we compromise
some people think compromise at the
highest level you know a marriage you
gotta compromise I don't know about that
I think you do well you know you don't
yeah you have to compromise why do I
have to compromise I don't want to
compromise maybe she has the better
choice but you have to compromise
because it's healthy for marriage it's
healthy for business I don't think so
the highest level is collaborate what is
collaborating means maybe your idea is
better than mine maybe spending the
million dollars in the area that you are
suggesting is gonna give us 80% return
on the million maybe my million is gonna
make us forty percent maybe you are
right if I compromise we meet halfway
I give you half a million I keep a half
a million no no collaboration means tell
me what you think and here's what I'm
thinking that's what you're thinking
okay got mom I hate to say it she's
right I'm gonna go with your side that's
the five levels by the way please don't
take this as me the
expert is saying this I'm automatically
putting myself at the highest category
I've had to work to get up to this point
the bigger I wanted to get with my
business every single year I had to
remind myself to get closer to
collaboration and lower compromised
lower than being just a person that
accommodates I wanted to get to
collaboration and adult my business
growth so now now that we know the five
levels you have to assess yourself and
say I think I'm level two I think I'm
level three by the way this is not a
scoring system on whoever gets the high
score wins you should have to be very
honest with yourself against address the
conflict with yourself maybe you are
level one maybe you are level two and
how has that worked for you if it hasn't
work for you then you got to change